to protest in russia takes a certain
amount of courage as it comes with the
likelihood that you'll be detained often
violently
this is petersburg where they were
chanting no to war
an independent monitoring group reported
protests in 44 russian cities on sunday
including here in kazan
and in russia's eastern city of erkutsk
it is a crime both against ukraine and
against russia i think it is killing
ukraine and russia i'm outraged i
haven't slept for three nights and i
think we must now declare very loudly
that we don't want to be killed and we
don't want ukraine to be killed
these have been the first significant
attempts at nationwide protests in
almost a year since the jailing of
kremlin critic alexei navalny here in
moscow the police are making it very
difficult for people to try and protest
anyone who so much as lingers in a
suspected gathering area is taken away
for questioning protesters don't worry
the kremlin but sanctions and
international condemnation of the
invasion of ukraine have prompted
vladimir putin to put russia's
deterrence forces which include nuclear
arms on high alert
dear colleagues as you can see
not only do western countries take
unfriendly measures against our country
in the economic dimension i mean the
illegal sanctions that everyone knows
about very well but also the top
officials of leading nato countries
allow themselves to make aggressive
statements with regards to our country
that is why i ordered defence minister
and chief of the general staff to put
russian army deterrence forces on high
combat alert
outside the kremlin at the tomb of the
unknown soldier monuments represent the
losses suffered by soviet cities in
world war ii
on sunday flowers started appearing on
the one for kiev but only until the
police realized what was going on
in russia there can be no visible
opposition to the war on ukraine
bernard smith al jazeera moscow